I call them The Impossible galaxies but
of course the galaxies are real what's
impossible is The Big Bang
[Music]
Theory so let's start at the beginning
the Big Bang is an explanation for the
phenomenon that's been observed for 100
years that light from distant objects is
shifted to the red to the long end of
the spectrum and we know that because
light from any element produces bright
and dark lines and this pattern of
bright and dark lines is well understood
from experiments on Earth and we can see
that it's shifted more and more to the
red as the galaxies become more distant
the question is is this due as Hubble
himself thought to something that
happens to the light that causes it to
lose energy as it travels
or as in the Big Bang is it due to the
physical expansion of the universe
that creates a stretching of the light
and shifting into the red well it turns
out that there's a critical test between
these two Alternatives which was
discovered uh by Tolman back 19 uh 90
years ago and this has to do with an
optical illusion that occurs because of
the expansion of the universe when an
object is closer to us when the light is
emitted it looks larg
larger much
larger than it than when we observe it
today so a Galaxy at a red shift of let
us say three is going to look much
larger today than if the universe was
not
expanded so this produces the peculiar
phenomena which nonetheless there is no
debate about if the universe is
expanding at r shifts more than
1.6 the apparent diameter of an object
starts to increase with greater distance
instead of decreasing now of course if
the universe is not expanding if space
is as the space is here on Earth more
distant objects look smaller according
to that simple uh linear
equation the angular size of galaxies of
the same Luminosity at difference Z is a
test of the expansion of the universe so
let's look at the
difference if you hypothesize a Galaxy
the size of the Milky Way let's say or
any fixed size then if the Big
Bang is true you predict a rising curve
of angular observed size if it's not
true you predict a declining so there's
a big difference that grows with red
shift if you turn this from prediction
to
Observation this means that for Galaxies
at a given angular
size the linear size the true size how
many million how many thousand light
years across they are is going to be
different for the two hypotheses so
they're in the opposite direction for
the no big bang if you have an object of
a constant size it's going to be bigger
in true size the more distant it is the
moon is great deal bigger than my hand
even though I can cover the moon with my
fist in the Big Bang that's not true and
more distant objects of the
same uh angular size have a smaller and
smaller intrinsic
size well what did the hobo Space
Telescope discover about this Ricardo
and I and our colleagues examined this
at Great length and we discovered that
in samples from 10 to 100 galaxies and
each of these dots is the mean of many
galaxies at Red shifts extending out to
5 a half the mean radi was exactly the
same if it was calculated on the basis
of a non-expanding universe exactly what
we
predicted
so this was a very good
prediction and it did get published in
the
in in the same
Journal so we were not really jumping
into the dark when we predicted in the
paper that we had to self-publish online
that for resolved galaxies of a given
mass or Luminosity the angular radius
will decline as 1 / Z so we
predicted from this formula that what we
would see with jws T is the same as what
we had seen with Hubble Space Telescope
galaxies of the same size as our own
Milky
Way so what happens this is actual
observations from Hubble and from
jwst so these blue dots are the galaxies
as calculated if the universe is not
expanding and as you can see both with
these are the brightest galaxies that
are observable by either telescope for
either HST or
jwst they are indeed in the same range
there galaxies like ours that are tens
of thousands of parex
across if you take the expanding
Universe calculations from the same data
you get these orange dots and these
orange dots show that these are
hypothesizing galaxies much smaller than
our own even with Hubble and absolutely
tiny with
um uh jwst if you look at the icons to
the left this gives you a good idea of
the contrast this would be a Galaxy the
size of the Milky Way this dot would be
a hypothesized Galaxy if the uh Universe
were expanding and remember these are
galaxies that by their light we can tell
are as luminous or more luminous than
the Milky Way But hundreds of times
smaller so this is just physically
impossible because it's physically
impossible for these galaxies that are
supposedly the predecessors of our
galaxies to grow 100
fold but actually things are going to
get worse for the the Big Bang even
though this is already conclusive
evidence against it there's an
independent way of measuring the radius
independent of the question of whether
the universe is expanding or not which
is earlier this
year an existing very large telescope a
radio telescope on Earth called Alma
started taking Spectra of galaxies and
from these very sensitive Spectra you
get these lines that are characteristic
of the various elements from the height
of these lines you can determine
unequivocally what the mass of the
galaxy is the mass m in this formula
from the width of these lines you can
determine what the velocity of rotation
of the Galaxy is from Newton's law of
gravity we can determine that there's a
minimum radius that this galaxy must be
which is which is simply this formula
which is proportional to m / V ^ 2 * the
universal gravitational constant so very
basic physics you can get an unequivocal
measure of the minimum
radius so for Galaxies that were
observed at a red shift of between four
and five what do we find I took the
four most precisely measured galaxies
non ones that made my point the best but
the most precisely
measured and I determined the red dots
are the minimum radius based on this
independent measurement which is if you
can't read this this a little dim 10
kilop Parx
about the green dots are the radius
measured from the angular radius and the
formula using nonexpanding space so as
you can see they are all comfortably
above the red minimum radius the blue
dots and here's the punch line are the
radi calculated using the expanding
universe and they are from two to four
times less than the minimum physically
possible radius so you know I call them
The Impossible galaxies but of course
the galaxies are real what's impossible
is The Big Bang Theory now this is going
to get much worse with
jwst because we're going to get the same
galaxies out at twice as uh far uh twice
the red shift and instead of being two
to four times impossibly small they're
going to be 6 to 12 times impossibly
small why does this all matter you know
why does it matter whether the universe
is expanding or not to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit I a.tv for more debates and talks
from the world's leading thinkers on
today's biggest ideas